let's take you live to hillsborough in
county down uh the president and vice
president of sinn fein uh mary lou
macdonald who's speaking now uh
alongside michelle o'neal
they have just finished their meeting
with prime minister boris johnson
we have no clarity by this absolute
certainty and that is that the time for
the executive is now
the time to appoint a first and deputy
first minister is now to appoint a
speaker to the assembly is now people
have had their election it's been a long
election campaign goodness knows and now
is the time for people to get back to
work and here's here's the real kicker
right there is an established mechanism
through the joint committee to deal with
those elements of the protocol that need
to be smoothed out finessed
and altered
the prime minister is aware of that
the government in dublin is aware of
that the european institutions are aware
of that and yet here we find ourselves
in a situation where the british prime
minister is quite willing to act uh in
in coordination with the dup with very
very unacceptable obstructionist tactics
and what that says
to the population people who are
struggling now
to pay for their groceries and to keep
the show on the road in their own homes
and their own families is just
astounding it's not acceptable in the
north of ireland and i dare say it would
not be acceptable anywhere else in
england in boris johnson's own backyard
would he deem it acceptable for one
minute
to say to struggling families and
workers struggle on struggle on why we
hold a veto on the government that can
deliver a few it's not acceptable there
it's not acceptable here we've made that
very clear to him um we did not manage
to convince him
of the error of his ways but be very
very clear that we will persist on these
matters
the words that we needed to hear vicky
is that the british government would
honor the established mechanisms and
channels that have been agreed
to smooth out to consider and to resolve
the hiccups the difficulties that arrive
arise from the application of the
protocol everybody agrees there is no
difference there is no division of minds
on that matter where the line is drawn
is when the british government says with
the chest stuck out that they will act
unilaterally that they will legislate
unilaterally and where the british
government very cynically i have to say
um says to unionism or a section of
political unionism that they can have a
veto on progress they can have no such
veto democracy has to rule uh in the end
and the democratic wishes of the people
have to be respected and be very clear
and i i i'm flanked by two uh former
ministers of the executive and the the
first minister elect everybody is very
clear that whatever people's differences
are points of divergence everybody wants
government everybody wants the executive
established so what we needed to hear
from boris johnson and we need to hear
yes
is that the executive must be formed no
ifs no buts no conditionality and no
unionist visa
that we're on the agenda today um
well we expect to see um delivery in
terms of abortion services oct the
cultural package within the next week
that's been given on the issue of legacy
um we have challenged again the british
government's approach to all of this
they are they are absolutely clear that
the amnesty they proposed is
unacceptable it's been roundly rejected
by all shades of opinion uh here on the
island of ireland and indeed condemned
internationally
what their alternative proposal is we
don't know what we do know is that many
many moons ago at stormont house
agreement was found agreement was found
a consensus was found amongst the
political parties here and the the
british government the tories have been
really really very negative and have
helped well we seem to have lost the
line there to hillsborough you were
listening to shin fame president mary
lou macdonald speaking there let's
rejoin her actually here she
is boris johnson and secondly are you
committed to power sharing even if the
prime minister overrides the protocol
will you still be committed to that well
firstly we have not given up on power
sharing or the executive fire from us
parish sharing is the only game in town
working together is the only option
there is no plan b we live here together
we have to work together we have to make
progress together and we are up for that
we will we will work night and day to
make that uh happen
the unfortunate thing is that the
british government now is playing a game
of brinkmanship with the european
institutions
indulging a section of political
unionism which believes that it can hold
a veto and frustrate and hold society uh
to ransom that's what needs to change
our commitment to power sharing our
commitment to working in partnership
will never change and michelle o'neill
uh will say i'm sure for herself how
anxious she is to take office and to
lead for everybody we campaigned on the
basis of establishing functioning
partnership institutions electing a
first minister for all when we said that
we meant that and we believe that in in
the current circumstances so many people
irrespective of how they voted
legitimately expect that they see
functioning government now and and we're
committed to that
sorry sorry there are other people if
the prime minister introduces
legislation overriding the protocol is
that a red line for you
when it comes to power sharing there are
no red lines for us when it comes to
power sharing bar
that power is shared and that others
step up and nominate now let me tell you
there is no circumstances we envisage in
which the protocol can be wished away
spirited way or indeed legislated away
the notion that in the mother of all
parliaments as it boasts
that there would be an attempt to
legislate to break international law is
shocking it's breathtaking and i we find
ourselves astounded that members of that
the house of commons our lords would
even countenance such a proposal
what we want is the
british government the european
institutions to sort out the issues
about the protocol to smooth its
implementation we accept that but what
we want is is government to be resumed
power sharing to be resumed and for the
first time
in the north for the first time a huge
benchmark of equality
where we have for the first time a
nationalist first minister acting for
all and taking office
directly i know you're worried we're
heading towards a
well look it was um it was a lively uh
meeting with us he's it's tough i think
uh is the word i mean we're not we're
not here to uh
to beat around the bush or to to to try
and sugarcoat anything this is a very
serious situation this is a very serious
situation it is unacceptable
for families for children for
communities that are in the most
desperate in some cases of hard times
that politics that the british prime
minister says to those people those
workers and those families too bad
too bad we have to delay too bad because
others have a veto on their needs the
people's needs being prioritized and
addressed that that to our mind is
is is scandalous actually i would use
the word scandalous shameful i mean
people are struggling right now with the
course the living crisis we're just 10
days past our election the people came
out in large numbers they voted for
politics to work they voted for parties
to work together they voted for a local
executive they'll start to put money in
their pockets they've voted to fix our
health service and they're being denied
all of that by the dup and they're being
supported by boris johnson and co who
we've just met in this building that is
not acceptable it's not tolerable and it
shouldn't go on for one day longer we
were we're determined we're very
determined to be an executive we're very
determined to turn up for people as we
promised the whole way out the election
campaign it is now time to get into that
executive and do business and actually
respond to the public's needs what boris
johnson is sponsoring in the dup is
nonsense and it's madness at this time
next one
thank you nick bbc news night and mary
lou mcdonald you've said that it was a
tough meeting and it was a lively
meeting but i can ask you about boris
johnson's fundamental point which is
that the northern ireland protocol has
lost the confidence of the unionist
party the humanist community not just
the dup and you need to have power
sharing here and at the heart of the
good friday agreement is that both
communities have confidence in the
governance here and unionists don't have
confidence so he's saying i'm not
wrecking the protocol but i have to
reform it to win the confidence of the
unionist communities to get power
sharing
well let me answer uh you as as we as we
answered the the the prime minister in
in the following terms firstly nobody
including unionism has a veto on
progress that the majority of mlas
returned to the assembly support the
protocol that's a fact
there is no call for a consensus or for
a cross-community consensus for the
protocol that's a legal fiction the
british government is peddling this myth
to try and dress up what we regard as a
very very negative approach to the good
friday agreement and its institutions
and to try and dress it up as being
pro-good friday agreement it's nothing
of the sort the proposed course of
action by boris johnson and his
government can cause nothing other than
instability insecurity and hardship for
people let me say again
those areas of the protocol where people
wish to see smoothed out altered there
is a mechanism for that to happen please
don't miss that there is a forum there
the european institutions have engaged
have made progress will engage but they
need a good faith partner in the british
government so
rather than
rather than playing these games
and giving cover to the dup for what is
essentially a wrecker's charter and
holding society to ransom the british
government could act constructively and
could be clear and could say to one and
all the issues in the protocol will be
resolved through the agreed mechanisms
and that boris johnson as prime minister
will lead and drive that effort and in
the meantime for the good of one and all
the executive needs to be formed by the
way the ulster unionist party's position
is that they are willing to enter in
executives just so as we're clear it is
one party the dup that is holding all
others to ransom at a time as michelle
has said when when people are facing
into a positive living crisis that we
haven't seen in 20 or 30 years and by
the way it's not going to get any easier
it's going to get much more difficult
that cost of living crisis into the
autumn and facing into the winter thank
you thanks folks
mcdonald and vice president michelle
o'neill they're addressing the assembled
press pack after their meeting with the
prime minister boris johnson it's just
been just over a week now since the
northern ireland election champaign the
largest party in the assembly ready uh
to form a power sharing government but
as they said they feel they are being
held to ransom by the dup and the
sticking point that northern ireland
protocol